if you're a 90s kid you probably
recognize this
[Music]
that's enough most of you already know
that faster than youtube's copyright
system does it's the theme song to drake
and josh and i like many people grew up
as a minor watching it little did i know
drake bell one of the stars was
returning the favor for some of us
now i'm not here to comment on some of
the legal issues that have arisen since
then because ultimately they're not my
business and i've heard that they're
actually not that major of issues
they're minor now instead the reason i
come before you today is to warn you
about a major issue if you're following
drake bell still he's been secretly
getting paid to shill nfts now i know
that's a shock
right but even more shocking is i
confronted drake bell on twitter about
this and he lied to me and i'm here to
expose it to you guys today just to
prove once again the blockchain doesn't
lie right and you can run but eventually
we will catch you now for a little
background before we get into this uh
drake bell i can't believe this is a
real story it's insane uh he's turned
into something of a sam pepper type
figure you remember guys remember sam
right from save the kids he's washed up
social media figure pivoted into
shilling altcoins twitter and behind the
scenes was getting paid now drake bell
sort of joined that playbook guilty but
i didn't know about that at first as
we'll get into but he thought he could
get away with it but like all social
media stars they don't actually
understand how crypto works and so we
caught him we caught him doing some very
naughty things to his fans
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host coffee zilla the internet
detective and this is a bit of a weird
one if you guys asked me at the
beginning of this year the weirdest
things that were going to happen to me
drake bell dropping into my dms and
lying to me was not in the cards right
him getting caught red-handed 4k
not what i had planned because he's a
real celebrity and we are on the
internet um you know not disparaging
youtube but i just thought
it was sort of out of our you know thing
so for a little context drake bell has
been running this nft shill game scam
game i don't know what you really want
to call it you can call it all of those
um let's bring down the board and show
you what i'm talking about and i know
most of you guys are saying steven you
got trolled by a bot account but no no
it's really him this is his profile
right here drake bell at drake bell
follows you 4.5 million followers and
his entire twitter timeline is these nft
scams and again not all nfts are scams
but the ones that hire these ridiculous
influencers to promote them all the time
let's be honest right good morning one
nft should i buy today share some cool
projects and then you look at his actual
timeline and it's just him promoting a
bunch of these projects things like this
metamods dropping in six hours public
mint and he promotes this thing you guys
have probably never heard of for the
past several months he's been doing this
and people started to wonder if he
wasn't getting paid behind the scenes in
fact one of his fans came to me and told
me that he was now
i didn't think anything of it you know a
lot of these guys are promoting this
stuff but it wasn't until drake bell
himself dropped in my dms and told me
basically hey man i'm here to set the
record straight if you have any
questions let me know that i thought
something was definitely weird because
generally i mean i'm not saying you
you're guilty if you come to me but i
hadn't tweeted about him i hadn't said
anything and so for him to come come
it's like someone knocking on your door
and going i didn't do anything you know
you're just like wait wait what
you know you'd show up at the police
station look i just want to clear the
record i didn't do anything and be like
hmm wait tell me more about what you
didn't do so he told me that and i look
i said look i don't know anything just
tell me uh here's what he said that your
accuser said hear the allegations you've
been promoting a bunch of these things
and being paid behind the scenes and
while i was doing that since my
curiosity was peaked at this point i
decided i'd investigate this man a
little bit and so what do you know guys
i go to the blockchain and i found his
profile
drakebell.eth now right away i noticed
some problems if you scroll through his
transaction history occasionally you'll
notice stuff like this
200 keys.eve paying drake bell 0.25
ether which is about a thousand dollars
and they paid him the same day as he
promoted an nft called 200 keys here's
the promotion he did the same day he got
this payment 200 keys is a collection of
nft key chains that unlock trades in nfc
collection blah blah blah you know what
i mean they're having 70 thousand
dollars to give the giveaways blah blah
blah and there he is shilling it on
october 10th that's the day that he got
paid now i was pretty concerned about
this because obviously does he say
anywhere that it's an ad that he's been
paid to do this no and this is an
increasing problem in crypto nobody
discloses anything because it's bad if
you say you're shilling instead people
just do it under the radar and hope that
nobody ever finds out but of course we
do so i actually end up confronting
drake about this and i say i send him
the screenshot of the thing because he's
asking me look if you want to clear it
up whatever so i send him this and i say
you know what do you want to comment so
i sent him this i sent him the payment i
say example you promoted 200 keys but
got paid a thousand bucks behind the
scenes this is a problem drake drake
responds i didn't make a thousand bucks
i got free nfts buddy now this was a
bold move i hadn't thought of this he
told me he got paid enough seats and
sure enough if you go to his nft
collection
it does say he has three 200 keys and a
piece so i think to myself huh that's
weird maybe the .25 ethy got paid were
fermenting as you know sometimes you
have to pay minting fees when um minting
these things so i say minting fees he
says what i said the 200 keys they paid
you 0.25 eth the day of your tweet he
said no i received two free mints try
again i thought this was a bit
condescending but i was like all right
whatever um so i say is this your wallet
we're back to this guys so i say is this
your wallet and i show him the
transaction id where he got paid and so
he responds now now watch this yes he
gave me two keys and i used the eath to
mint more now again this is different
from what he first told me which is all
i got was three nfts but i think to
myself well maybe i just misunderstood
maybe this is all really on the up and
up maybe i'm the one in the wrong here
but i don't think so i got a weird hunch
about this so he said oh she did get
paid 25 eat 0.258 like i said and he
said no i didn't get paid i minted keys
with the eth he sent very clear
statement here what do you want from me
exactly well now at this point now that
we have a very clear statement from him
about what he did i go to the polygon
transaction that's where all of this
occurred was on the polygon chain and i
find those transactions now guys
according to um the the 200 keys website
these nfts cost 50 matic to mint so i go
to drake bell's polygon address and i
find the 200 keys and i go and i look
how much he paid for these and the first
one he paid zeromatic for the second one
he also paid zeromatic for but that
should be expected remember that's what
he told us happened remember he said he
gave me two keys and i used the eath to
mint more he has three of them so he
must have paid for the third one however
when we look up the third key he
also paid zero
so he
he's just lying and just like lying
about something that's so publicly
verifiable it's shocking guilty so i
responded you did not make keys with the
eighth 200 keys that it sent i could see
the transaction history you did not pay
a fee for any of the three you meant it
and he responds this is my favorite part
they were gifted i yeah i'm confused i i
can't get gifted in fts i'm confused
what you're so upset about
dude it's just lie after lie after light
it's like drake what happened bud drake
drake and josh the payments weren't
enough you broke what why are you doing
this for a thousand dollars you're lying
to a youtuber for a thousand dollars
it has gone too far it's just such a
dumb thing to lie about by the way just
say like yeah i showed it they paid me a
thousand bucks i didn't say ad i'm sorry
instead he's like what no i didn't do it
and now that's even funnier that's a
better story that's it funnier than you
just got paid a thousand dollars which
is kind of sad to be honest but i think
poor judgment seems to be a recurring
theme here that's basically the story i
don't know that's
basically it i caught drake bell in a
multiple lies let's count them first it
was oh i didn't get paid at all then it
was oh i'm just i used it to mint things
then it's oh what i can't get a gift i
can't have a gift from an artist what's
the big deal guys
the crazy thing is is that never during
this entire conversation with him even
after that did he ever show any remorse
or think that he was at all in the wrong
um and it just goes to show like when
everyone's getting away with it at this
scale because obviously drake bell is
not the only one who uh who's doing this
right now not disclosing that he's
basically advertising for these nft
companies shilling them to his fans so
they buy in and get wrecked he's not the
only one doing it and he even brought up
to me well hey why are you calling me
out dude everyone's doing it right now
dude you should call out him he's
getting paid more he actually pointed
out some people we're getting paid more
that we're probably going to talk about
soon
but um he basically said what why are
you picking on me and i've had that
experience multiple times recently guys
i want you guys to understand these
influencers they don't feel bad
ironically they feel offended when you
call them out you go hey you have to
disclose that per the ftc they go hey
why are you picking on me guilty if just
any kind of regulation came in all of
this would stop the problem is right now
everybody's getting away with it so
these guys rather than being ashamed of
what they do well they do lie about it
they are ashamed but they are just so
flagrant with it where even when you do
catch them and you do call them out they
go why are you picking on me
it's like it's crazy man so um this is
my plea to the ftc to all these guys
watching this space right now listen to
me right now i know these guys i talked
to these guys these guys showing these
projects right now they've never been
more flagrant they've never been more
willing to do this because right now
there are no consequences the biggest
consequences to drake bell is me making
a video about him that's the that's the
highest form of punishment right now and
that's no punishment at all i'm sorry
sorry if i seem like i'm getting upset
at the end here but i'm a little pissed
cause i'm like yes it's drake bell's
fault but also isn't it the fault that
none of these guys are getting in
trouble like of course people are going
to continue doing it because nobody ever
goes down for this stuff so i'm just
saying
if this is such a if this is a rule
right this is an ftc guideline the ftc
themselves say that you have to disclose
this stuff in their disclosures 101 for
social media influencers how about a
little consequences right ftc right i
mean i think that's fair to say right
how about a little consequences for
these guys in the meantime i will
continue calling them out you cut you
guys can rely on that that's maybe the
only thing you can rely on and please
guys if you like the show please support
this work by pumping the stock i am but
a man and i need your help
we are uh at 800 000 subscribers it's
been shocking to get here so fast so
thank you to each and every one of you
who have been doing your job every day
pumping the stock liking and subscribing
i thank each and every one of you and i
appreciate where we've gotten we will
continue to call these guys out until
something is done anyways that's
basically it for now see in the next
[Music]
you